GILBERT STRANG: So
let me use the mic
to introduce Alex Townsend,
who taught here at MIT--
taught Linear Algebra
18.06 very successfully.
And then now he's at
Cornell on the faculty,
still teaching
very successfully.
And he was invited
here yesterday
for a big event
over in Engineering.
And he agreed to give a talk
about a section of the book--
section 4.3--
which, if you look at it, you'll
see is all about his work.
And now you get to hear
from the creator himself.
OK.
ALEX TOWNSEND: OK.
Thanks.
Thank you, Gil.
Thank you for inviting me here.
I hope you're
enjoying the course.
Today I want to tell
you a little about why
there so many matrices that
are low rank in the world.
So as computational
mathematicians--
Gil and myself-- we come across
low-rank matrices all the time.
And we started wondering,
as a community, why?
What is it about the problems
that we are looking at?
What makes low-rank
matrices appear?
And today I want to
give you that story--
or at least an
overview of that story.
So for this class, x is going
to be n by n real matrix.
So nice and square.
And you already know, or
are very comfortable with,
the singular values of a matrix.
So the singular values
of a matrix, as you know,
are a sequence of numbers
that are monotonically
non-increasing that tell
us all kinds of things
about the matrix x.
For example, the number
of nonzero singular values
tell us the rank
of the matrix x.
And they also, you probably
know, tell us how well a matrix
x can be approximated
by a low-rank matrix.
So let me just write two
facts down that you already
are familiar with.
So here's a fact--
that, if I look at the number of
non-zero singular values in x--
so I'm imagining there's going
to be k non-zero singular
values--
then we can say a
few things about x.
For example, the rank
of x, as we know, is k--
the number of non-zero
singular values.
But we also know from the
SVD that we can decompose x
into a sum of rank 1 matrices--
in fact, the sum of k of them.
So because x is rank
k, we can write down
a low-rank representation for
x, and it involves k terms,
like this.
Each one of these vectors
here is a column vector.
So if I draw this
pictorially, this guy
looks like this, right?
And we have k of them.
So because x is rank k, we
can write x as a sum of k
rank 1 matrices.
And we also have an initial
fact that we already know--
that the dimension of
the column space of x
is equal to k, and the
same with the row space.
So the column space of x
equals the row space of x--
the dimension-- and
they all equal k.
And so there are three
facts we can determine
from looking at this sequence of
singular values of a matrix x.
Of course, the singular
value sequence is unique.
X defines its own
singular values.
What we're interested in
here is, what makes x?
What are the properties
of x that make
sure that the singular
values have a lot
of zeros in that sequence?
Can we try to understand what
kind of x makes that happen?
And we really like matrices
that have a lot of zeros
here, for the following reason--
we say x is low rank if
the following holds, right?
Because if we wanted to
send x to our friend--
we're imagining x as
picture where each entry
is a pixel of that image.
If that matrix-- that
image-- was low rank,
we could send the picture
to our friend in two ways.
We could send one every
single entry of x.
And for us to do
that, we would have
to send n squared
pieces of information,
because we'd have
to send every entry.
But if x is
sufficiently low rank,
we could also send our
friend the vectors--
u, u1, v1, uk, up to vk.
And how much pieces
of data would we
have to send our
friend to get x to them
if we sent in the low-rank form?
Well, there's 2n
here, 2n here numbers.
There's k of them.
So we'd have to
send 2kn numbers.
And we strictly
say a matrix is low
rank if it's more efficient
to send x to our friend
in low-rank form then
in full-rank form.
So this, of course, by
a little calculation,
just shows us that,
provided the rank is
less than half the
size of the matrix,
we are calling the
matrix low rank.
Now, often, in practice,
we demand more.
We demand that k is much
smaller than this number,
so that it's far more efficient
to send our friend the matrix x
in low-rank form than
in full-rank form.
So the colloquial use
of the word low rank
is kind of this situation.
But this is the strict
definition of it.
So what do low-rank
matrices look like?
And to do that, I have
some pictures for you.
I have some flags--
the world flags.
So these are all matrices x--
these examples-- because their
flags happen to not be square.
I hope you can all see this.
But the top row here
are all matrices
that are extremely low rank.
For example, the Austria flag--
if you want to send
that to your friend,
that matrix is of rank 1.
So all you have to do is
send your friend two vectors.
You have to tell your friend the
column space and the row space.
And there's only the
dimensions of one of both.
For the English flag, you
need to send them two column
vectors and two row vectors--
u1, v1, u2 and v2.
And as we go down this row, they
get slowly fuller and fuller
rank.
So the Japanese
flag, for example,
is low rank but not that small.
The Scottish flag is
essentially full rank.
So it's very inefficient to send
your friend the Scottish flag
in low-rank form.
You're better off sending
almost every single entry.
So what do low-rank
matrices look like?
Well, if the matrix
is extremely low rank,
like rank 1, then when
you look at that matrix--
like here, like the flag--
it's highly aligned
with the coordinates--
with the rows and columns.
So if it's rank 1, the
matrix is highly aligned--
like the Austria flag.
And of course, as we add
in more and more rank here,
the situation gets a bit blurry.
For example, once we get into
the medium rank situation,
which is a circle,
it's very hard
to see that the circle is
actually, in fact, low rank.
But what I'm going to
do was try to understand
why the Scottish flag
or diagonal patterns--
particularly a bad
example for low rank.
So I'm going to take
the triangular flag
to examine that more carefully.
So the triangular
flag looks like--
I'll take a square matrix and
I'll color in the bottom half.
So this matrix is the matrix
of ones below the diagonal.
And I'm interested in this
matrix and, in particular,
its singular values,
to try to understand
why diagonal patterns
are not particularly
useful for low-rank compression.
And this matrix of all ones has
a really nice property that,
if I take its inverse,
it looks a lot like--
getting close to
Gil's favorite matrix.
So if I take the
inverse of this matrix--
it has an inverse because it's
got ones on the diagonal--
then its inverse is
the following matrix,
which people familiar with
finite difference schemes
will notice the
familiarity between that
and the first order finite
difference approximation.
In particular, if I go
a bit further and times
two of these
together, and do this,
then this is essentially
Gil's favorite matrix,
except one entry happens
to be different--
ends up being this
matrix, which is
very close to the second order,
central, finite difference
matrix.
And people have
very well studied
that matrix and know
its eigenvalues,
its singular values--
they know everything
about that matrix.
And you'll remember
that if we know
the eigenvalues of a
matrix, like x transpose x,
we know the singular
values of x.
So this allows us
to show, by the fact
that we know that, that the
singular values of this matrix
are not very
amenable to low rank.
They're all non-zero, and
they don't even decay.
So I'm getting this from--
I rang up Gil, and Gil
tells me these numbers.
That allows us to work out
exactly what the singular
values of this matrix
are, from the connection
to finite differences.
And so we can understand
why this is not
good by looking at
the singular values.
So the first singular value
of x from this expression
is going to be
approximately 2n over pi.
And from this expression,
again, for the last guy--
the last singular
value of x is going
to be approximately a half.
So these singular
values are all large.
They're not getting
close to zero.
If I plotted these singular
values on a graph--
so here's the first
singular value, the second,
and the n-th--
then what would the
graph look like?
Well, plot these numbers.
Divide by this guy
so that they all
are bounded between 1 and 0
because of the normalization,
because I divided
by sigma 1 of x.
And so we can plot
them, and they will
look like this kind of thing.
This number happens
to be here where
they come to be
pi over 4n, which
is me dividing this number by
this number, approximately.
So triangular patterns are
extremely bad for low rank.
We need things-- or we at
least intuitively think
that we need things-- aligned
with the rows and columns,
but the circle case happens
to also be low rank.
And so what happened
to the Japanese flag?
Why is the Japanese flag
convenient for low rank?
Well it's the fact
that it's a circle,
and there's lots of
symmetry in a circle.
So if I try to look at the rank
of a circle, the Japanese flag,
then I can bound this rank by
decomposing the Japanese flag
into two things.
So this is going to be less
than or equal to the rank of sum
of two matrices, and I'll do it
so that the decomposition works
out.
I have the circle.
I'm going to cut out a
rank one piece that lives
in the middle of this circle.
OK?
And I'm going to cut out
a square from the interior
of that circle.
OK?
And I can figure out-- of
course the rank is just bounded
by the sum of those two ranks.
This guy is bounded by rank
one because it's highly
aligned with the grid.
So this guy is
bounded by rank one.
So this thing here plus 1.
And now I have to
try to understand
the rank of this piece.
Now this piece has
lots of symmetry.
For example, we know that
the rank of that matrix
is the dimension
of the column space
and the dimension
of the row space.
So when we look at this
matrix, because of symmetry,
if I divide this matrix
in half along the columns,
all the columns on the
left appear on the right.
So for example, the
rank of this matrix
is the same as the
rank of that matrix
because I didn't change
the column space.
OK?
Now I go again and
divide along the rows,
and now the row
dimension of this matrix
is the same as the top half,
because as I wipe out those,
I didn't change the
dimension of the row space
because the rows are
the same top-bottom.
And so this becomes the rank of
that tiny little matrix there.
And because it's small, it
won't have too large a rank.
So this is definitely less
than-- if I divide that up,
a little guy here looks like
that plus the other guy that
looks like that plus 1.
And so of course the row space
of this matrix cannot be very
high because this is
a very thin matrix.
There's lots of zeros in
that matrix, only a few ones.
And so you can go
along and do a bit
of trig to try to figure
out how many rows are
non-zero in this matrix.
And a bit of trig tells you--
well it depends on the radius
of this original circle.
So if I make the original
radius r of this Japanese flag,
then the bound that you
end up getting will be,
for this matrix, r 1
minus square root 2 over 2
for this guy.
That's a bit of trig.
I've got to make sure
that's an integer.
And then again, here it's the
same but for the column space.
So this is me just doing trig.
OK?
And that's bound on the rank.
It happens to be extremely good.
And if you work out what that
rank is and try to look back,
you will find it's
extremely efficient
to send the Japanese flag to
your friend in low rank form,
because it's not full rank
because these numbers are
so small.
So this comes out to be, like,
approximately 1/2 r plus 1.
So much smaller than
what you would expect,
because remember, a circle is
almost the anti-version version
of a line with the grid, but
yet, it's still low rank.
OK.
Now most matrices
that we come up
with in computational math are
not exactly of finite rank.
They are of numerical rank.
And so I'll just define that.
So the numerical
rank of a matrix
is very similar to the rank,
except we allow ourselves
a little bit of wiggle
room when we define it,
and so that amount of wiggle
room will be of parameter
called tol called epsilon.
That's a tolerance.
I'm thinking of
epsilon as a tolerance.
That's the amount of wiggle
room I'm going to give myself.
OK.
And we say that the
numerical rank--
I'll put an epsilon there
to denote numerical rank--
is k.
k is the first singular value,
or the last singular value,
above epsilon.
In the following sense, I'm
copying the definition above
but with epsilons
instead of zeros.
If this singular value is
less than epsilon, relatively,
and the kth one was not below.
So k plus 1 is the first
singular value below epsilon
in this relative sense.
So of course the rank of
0x, if that was defined,
is the same as the rank of x.
OK?
So this is just allowing
ourselves some wiggle room.
But this is actually what we're
interested more in practice.
All right?
I don't want to
necessarily send my friend
the flag to exact precision.
I would actually
be happy to send
my friend the flag up to
16 digits of precision,
for example.
They're not going to tell the
difference between those two
flags.
And if I can get away with
compressing the matrix
a lot more once I have a
little bit of wiggle room,
that would be a good thing.
So we know from the
Eckart and Young
that the singular values tell
us how well we can approximate
x by a low-rank matrix.
In particular, we know that the
k plus 1 singular value of x
tells us how well x can be
approximated by a rank k
matrix.
OK?
For example, when the rank was
exactly k, the sigma k plus 1
was 0, and then this
came out to be 0
and we found that x was
exactly a rank k matrix.
Here, because we have the
wiggle room, the epsilon,
we get an approximation,
not an exact.
So this is telling us how
well we can approximate
x by a rank k matrix.
OK?
That's what the singular
values are telling us.
And so this allows us to try
our best to compress matrices
but use low-rank
approximation rather
than doing things exactly.
And of course, on a computer,
when we're using floating point
arithmetic, or on a computer
because we always round numbers
to the nearest 16-digit number,
if epsilon was 16 digits,
your computer wouldn't
be able to tell
the difference between
x or x the rank k
approximation if this number
satisfied this expression.
Your computer would think of
x and xk as the same matrix
because it would
inevitably round both
to epsilon, within epsilon.
OK.
So what kind of matrices
are numerically of low rank?
Of course all low-rank matrices
are numerically of low rank
because the wiggle
room can only help you
but it's far more than that.
There are many
full-rank matrices--
matrices that don't have any
singular values that are zero--
but the singular values
decay rapidly to zero.
That are full-rank matrices
with low numerical rank because
of the wiggle room.
So for example, here
is the classic matrix
that fits this regime.
If I give you this, this is
called the Hilbert matrix.
This is a matrix
that happens to have
extremely low numerical
rank but it's actually
full rank, which means that I
can approximate H by a rank k
matrix where k is
quite small very well,
provided you give
me some wiggle room,
but it's not a low-rank
matrix in the sense
that if epsilon was zero
here, you didn't allow me
the wriggle room, all
the singular values
of this matrix are positive.
So it's of low numerical rank
but it's not a low-rank matrix.
The other classical
example which
motivated a lot of the
research in this area
was the Vandermonde matrix.
So here is the
Vandermonde matrix.
An n by n version of it.
Think of the xi's as real.
And this is Vandermonde.
This is the matrix
that comes up when
you try to do polynomial
interpolation at real points.
This is an extremely bad matrix
to deal with because it's
numerically low rank,
and often, you actually
want to solve a linear
system with this matrix.
And numerical low rank implies
that it's extremely hard
to invert, so numerical low
rank is not always good for you.
OK?
Often, we want the
inverse, which exists,
but it's difficult because
V has low numerical rank.
OK.
So people have been
trying to understand
why these matrices
are numerically
of low rank for a
number of years,
and the classic
reason why there are
so many low-rank matrices is
because the world is smooth,
as people say.
They say, the world is smooth.
That's why matrices are
of numerical low rank.
And to illustrate that
point, I will do an example.
So this is
classically understood
by a man called Reade
in 1983, and this
is what his reason was.
I have a picture of John Reade.
He's not very famous,
so I try to make
sure his picture gets around.
He's playing the piano.
It's, like, one of the only
pictures I could find of him.
So what is in this reason?
Why do people say this?
Well here's an example
that illustrates it.
If I take a polynomial
in two variables and I--
for example, this is a
polynomial of two variables--
and my x matrix
comes from sampling
that polynomial integers--
for example, this matrix--
then that matrix happens
to be of low rank--
mathematically of low rank,
with epsilon equals zero.
Why is that?
Well if I write down x
in terms of matrices,
you could easily see it.
So this is made up of
a matrix of all ones
plus a matrix of j-- so that's
1, 2, up to n, 1, 2, up to n,
because every entry
of that matrix
just depends on the row index.
And then this guy
depends on both j and k.
So this is a multiplication
table, right?
So this is n, 2, 4, up
to 2n, n, 2n, n squared.
OK.
Clearly, the matrix of all
ones is a rank one matrix.
The same with this guy.
The column space is
just of dimension one.
And the last guy also
happens to be of rank one
because I can write this
matrix in rank one form, which
is a column vector
times a row vector.
OK.
So this matrix x
is of rank three.
I guess at lowest rank three
is what I've actually shown.
OK.
Now of course this hasn't got
to numerical low rank yet,
so let's get ourselves there.
So Reade knew this, and
he said to himself, OK,
well if I can approximate--
if x is actually coming
from sampling a function,
and I approximate that
function by polynomial,
then I'm going to get myself
a low-rank approximation
and get a bound on
the numerical rank.
So in general, if I give you
a polynomial of two variables,
which can be written down--
it's degree n in both x and y.
Let's just keep these indexes
away from the matrix index.
I give you this such
polynomial, and I go away
and I sample it and
make a matrix X, then X,
by looking at each term
individually like I
did there, will have
low rank mathematically,
with epsilon equals zero.
This will have, at
most, m squared rank,
and if m is 3 or 4
or 10, it possibly
could be low because this
X could be a large matrix.
OK.
So what Reade did for the
Hilbert matrix was said,
OK, well look at that guy.
That guy looks like it's
sampling a function.
It looks like it's
sampling the function
1 over x plus y minus 1.
So he said to
himself, well, that x,
if I look at the Hilbert
matrix, then that
is sampling a function.
It happens to not
be a polynomial.
It happens to be this function.
But that's OK because sampling
polynomials, integers,
gives me low rank exactly.
Maybe sampling smooth
functions, functions like this,
can be well approximated
by polynomials
and therefore have
low numerical rank.
And that's what he
did in this case.
So he tried to find a p, a
polynomial approximation to f.
In particular, he looked
at exactly this kind
of approximation.
So he has some numbers
here so that things
get dissolved later.
And he tried to find a p that
did this kind of approximation.
So this approximates f.
And then he would develop a
low-rank approximation to X
by sampling p.
So he would say, OK, well if I
let y be a sampling of p, then
from the fact that f is a
good approximation to p,
y is a good approximation to
X. And so this has finite rank.
He wrote down that
this must hold.
And the epsilon comes out
here because these factors
were chosen just right.
The divide by n was chosen so
that the epsilon came out just
there.
OK?
So, for many years, that was
kind of the canonical reason
that people would
give, that, well,
if the matrix X is sampled
from a smooth function,
then we can approximate our
function by a polynomial
and get polynomial
rank approximations.
And therefore, the matrix X
will be of low numerical rank.
There's an issue
with this reasoning,
especially for the
Hilbert matrix,
that it doesn't
actually work that well.
So for example, if I take the
1,000 by 1,000 Hilbert matrix
and I look at its rank--
OK, well I've already told
you this is full rank.
You'll get 1,000.
All the singular
values are positive.
If I look at the numerical
rank of this 1,000
by 1,000 Hilbert matrix and I
compute it, I compute the SVD
and I look at how many are above
epsilon where epsilon is 10
to the minus 15,
so that means I can
approximate the 1,000
by 1,000 Hilbert matrix
by a rank 28 matrix
and only give up
15-- there will be exact 15
digits, which is a huge amount.
So this is what we
get in practice,
but Reade's argument here shows
that the rank of this matrix,
the numerical rank, is at most.
So it doesn't do a very good
job on the Hilbert matrix
for bounding the rank, right?
So Reade comes along,
takes this function.
He tries to find a polynomial
that does this, where
epsilon is 10 to the minus 15.
He finds that the
number of terms
that he needs in this
expression here is around 719,
and therefore, that's
the rank that he gets.
The bound on the numerical rank.
The trouble is that 719
tells us that this is not
of low numerical
rank, but we know
it is, so it's an
unsatisfactory reason.
So there's been
several people trying
to come up with more
appropriate reasons that
explain the 28 here.
And so one reason that
I've started to use
is another slightly
different way
of looking at things, which is
to say the world is Sylvester.
Now Sylvester, what
does that mean?
What does the word
"Sylvester" mean in this case?
It means that the
matrices satisfy
a certain type of equation
called the Sylvester equation,
and so the reason is really,
many of these matrices
satisfy a Sylvester equation,
and that takes the form--
for sum A, B, and C.
OK.
So X is your matrix of interest.
You want to show X is
of numerical low rank.
And the task at hand is
to find an A, B, and C so
that X satisfies that equation.
OK.
For example, the two matrices
I've had on the board
satisfy a Sylvester equation--
a Sylvester matrix equation.
There is an A, a B, and a
C for which they do this.
For example, remember
the Hilbert matrix,
which we have there still,
but I'll write it down again.
Has these entries.
So all we need to do
is to try to figure out
an A, a B, and then a
C so that we can make
it fit a Sylvester equation.
There's many different
ways of doing this.
The one that I like
is the following,
where if I put 1/2
here and 3/2 here,
all the way down to n minus
1/2, times this matrix--
so this is timesing the
top of this matrix by 1/2
and then 3/2 and then 5/2.
So we're basically timesing
each entry of this matrix
by j minus 1/2.
And then I do
something on the right
here, which I'm allowed to do
because I've got the B freedom,
and I choose this to be the
same up to a minus sign.
Then when you think about
this, what is it doing?
It's timing the jk entry--
this is-- by j minus 1/2.
That's what this is doing.
And what's this doing
is timesing the jk entry
by k minus 1/2.
So this is, in total,
timesing the jk entry
by j plus k minus 1/2 minus
1/2, which is minus 1,
so this is timesing the jk
entry by j plus k minus 1.
So it knocks out
the denominator.
And what we get from this
equation is a bunch of ones.
So in this case, A
and B are diagonal,
and C is the matrix of all ones.
OK?
We can also do this
for Vandermonde.
So Vandermonde, you'll
remember, looks like this.
And then over here,
we have this guy,
the matrix that appears with
polynomial interpolation.
OK.
So if I think about
this, I could also
come up with an A, B, and
C, and for example, here's
one that works.
I can stick the x's
on the diagonal.
So if you imagine what that
matrix on the left is doing,
it's timesing each
column by the vector x.
OK?
So the first column of this
matrix becomes x, the vector x.
The second becomes
the vector x squared,
where squared is
done entry-wise.
And then the third
entry is now x cubed,
and when we get to the
last, it's x to the n.
OK?
So that's like, multiply
each column by the vector x.
So if I want to try to
come up with a matrix--
so what's left is of low
rank, is like of this form.
What I can do is
shift the columns.
So I've noticed that
this product here,
this diagonal matrix, has
made the first column x.
So if I want to kill
off that column,
I can take the second column and
permute it to the first column.
I could take the third
column and permute it
to the second, the last
to the penultimate column here.
And that will actually
kill off a lot
of what I've created in
this matrix right here.
So let me write that down.
This is a circumshift matrix.
This does that permutation.
I've put a minus 1 there.
I could have put
any number there.
It doesn't make any difference.
But this is the one that
works out extremely nicely.
Now this zeros out lots of
things because of the way
I've done the multiplication
by x and the circumshift
of the columns.
And so the first column is zero
because this first column is x,
this first column is x,
so I've got x minus x.
This column was x squared
minus x squared, so I got zero,
and I just keep going along
until that last column.
That last column is a problem
because the last column
of this guy is x
to the n, whereas I
don't have x to the n in V, so
there are some numbers here.
OK.
You'll notice that
C in both cases
happens to be a low-rank matrix.
In these cases, it
happens to be of rank one.
And so people were
wondering, maybe it's
something to do with satisfying
these kind of equations that
makes these matrices
that appear in practice
numerically of low rank.
And after a lot of
work in this area,
people have come up
with a bound that
demonstrates that
these kind of equations
are key to understanding
numerical low rank.
So if X satisfies a Sylvester
equation, like this, and A
is normal, B is normal--
I don't really
want to concentrate
on those two conditions.
It's a little bit academic.
Then-- people have found
a bound on the singular
values of any matrix
that satisfies
this kind of
expression, and they
found this following bound.
OK, so here, the rank of C is r.
So that goes there.
So in our cases, the
two examples we have,
r is 1, so we can
forget about r.
This nasty guy here is
called the Zolotarev number.
E is a set that contains
the eigenvalues of A,
and F is a set that contains
the eigenvalues of B. OK.
Now it looks like we have
gained absolutely nothing
by this bound, because I've
just told you singular values
are bound by Zolotarev numbers.
That doesn't mean
anything to anyone.
It means a little bit
to me but not that much.
So the key to this bound--
the reason this is useful--
is that so many people have
worked out what these Zolotarev
numbers actually mean.
OK?
So these are two key
people that worked out
what this bound means.
And we have gained
a lot because people
have been studying this number.
This is, like, a
number that people
cared about from 1870
onwards to the present day,
and people have studied
this number extremely well.
So we've gained
something by turning it
into a more abstract problem
that people have thought
about previously,
and now we can go
to the literature on
Zolotarev numbers,
whatever they are, and discover
this whole literature of work
on this Zolotarev number.
And the key part--
I'll just tell you the key--
is that the sets E
and F are separated.
So for example, in the Hilbert
matrix, the eigenvalues of A
can be read off the diagonal.
What are they?
They are between minus
1/2 and n minus 1/2.
And the eigenvalues of B
lie in the set minus 1/2
minus n plus 1/2.
And the key reason
why the Hilbert matrix
is of low numerical
rank is the fact
that these two
sets are separated,
and that makes this Zolotarev
number gets small extremely
quickly with k.
Now you might wonder
why there is a question
mark on Penzl's name.
There is an unofficial
curse that's
been going on for a while.
Both these men died while
working on the Zolotarev
problem.
They both died at the age of 31.
One died by being hit
by a train, Zolotarev.
It's unclear whether he was
suicidal or it was accidental.
Penzl died at the age of 31
in the Canadian mountains
by an avalanche.
I am currently not yet 31
but going to be 31 very soon,
and I'm scared that
I may join this list.
OK.
But for the Hilbert matrix,
what you get from this analysis,
based on these
two peoples' work,
is a bound on the
numerical rank.
And the rank that you
get is, let's say,
a world record bound.
For the Hilbert matrix is 34,
which is not quite 28, not yet,
but it's far more
descriptive of 28 than 719.
And so this technique of
bounding singular values
by using these Zolotarev numbers
is starting to gain popularity
because we can finally answer
to ourselves why there are so
many low-rank matrices that
appear in computational math.
And it's all based on two
31-year-olds that died.
And so if you ever
wonder when you're
doing computational science
when a low rank appears
and the smoothness argument
does not work for you,
you might like to think about
Zolotarev and the curse.
OK, thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
GILBERT STRANG: Thank you
[INAUDIBLE] Excellent.
ALEX TOWNSEND: How
does it work now?
GILBERT STRANG: We're good.
Yeah.
ALEX TOWNSEND: I'm
happy to take questions
if we have a minute, if
you have any questions.
GILBERT STRANG: How
near of 31 are you?
ALEX TOWNSEND: [INAUDIBLE]
I get a spotlight.
I'm 31 in December.
GILBERT STRANG: Wow.
OK.
ALEX TOWNSEND: So they died
at the age of 31, so you know,
next year is the
scary year for me.
So I'm not driving anywhere.
I'm not leaving my
house until I become 32.
GILBERT STRANG: Well,
thank you [INAUDIBLE]
ALEX TOWNSEND: OK, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]